what's going on guys this is rob and
just wanted to touch base with you guys
for a few minutes let you guys know that
I'm having a lot of fun live streaming
video games it's really good to take a
break from the whole comic book thing
you know it's really nice to kind of
chill away from that for a minute or two
but I don't worry we're gonna be getting
back into it here in the next you know
we can have four so a couple weeks and
and get back to to cranking into to
comic books but I had a question for you
guys um one of the shorty awards I have
no ideas where those are what did the
guys send me a message it said you were
going to nominate me for the shorty
awards and I have no clue what that is I
mean I've heard the name you know I've
heard it discussed I saw online that
somebody had a saw I'm sorry their
website that and I guess maybe it's some
kind of thing for shorts or YouTube
content I don't I don't really know I
don't know how that works I know that
like I think PewDiePie won it last year
someone those lines but it's it's weird
like it's you know I feel like it's
something that I need to know I want to
know what this is I hate it when
somebody says I'm going to do something
for you then I have no idea what that
something is it just it drives me nuts
you know like like you know I love
surprises just much as anybody else but
sometimes I just want to know what's
going on so if one of you guys can
explain it to me what the shorty awards
is that they would be really awesome um
give the thing is we've been playing
borderlands 2 for the last few days or
so and and me and Dave and and a buddy
of mine Gavin have been having a great
time but even having a great time you
know doing doing this content and it's
it's really really interesting I'm in
case you guys were unaware of you know I
think we've mentioned a few times but of
course dave has this comics reviews
channel going on and and he's doing
really good at it like I really like the
content that he's putting out he
recently did a video about Civil War
really kind of you know basically
telling you guys whether or not civil
war is something worth buying this is
really not an element of civil war that
I'll cover in the Civil War video the
Civil War discussions I'll just give you
guys the explanation of what goes on in
Civil War Dave's video is really really
informative it's really really good and
I really enjoyed it so if you guys want
to know whether or not civil war is
worth by if you guys want to know
you know what you should do if you want
to buy Civil War if you want to get a
hold of civil war whether or not you
guys should buy all the books or whether
it's a better idea to simply by the
omnibus or something like that dave has
a video on that and its really really
helpful so you guys will find a video or
a link to that video down in the
description and definitely check it out
because like I said he's cranking along
really well but um yeah you know it's a
this is fun this whole comic book thing
this all kind of a community is fun like
you know we were talking during the live
stream you know with uh with me and me
and David and yeah we talked about
talking to the last year about this
whole comic book community thing that's
that's kind of been built and and one of
the guys mentioned that I guess I'd kind
of like found a niche or like created an
inch that that didn't really exist
before and you know I'm not sure how I
feel about that i mean like i said you
know i don't think i'm really doing
anything that is you know that's never
been done before i may just kind of be
doing a little bit different but there's
some great channels out there when it
comes to to county books i mean you've
got coming but girl and you know TV
little house we're actually going to
have Sal from TV little house on the
podcast I guess it'll be later today or
maybe it was earlier today depending on
when this video goes up it'll be during
the weekly cool podcast this week
bidding of course like i said is in
california for VidCon so I'm not even
sure if he's going to make the podcast
and it may be that we have to postpone
it although I really don't want to
because I told Sal it would be this week
and I don't know what kind of
adjustments these major schedule to
accommodate being on the weekly poll so
I don't really want you know um I guess
maybe like inconvenience them you don't
want to kind of be a pain in the ass
basically but yeah so you know it's
stuffs cranking along stuff is cranking
along it is it is cranking along so well
and it's just you know from the bottom
of my heart like I love you guys you
know you know
and you know like the way a youtuber
loves his subscribers you know I love
you guys you guys are so fantastic you
guys are so supportive and and I don't
you know I feel like it's something
that's just not said enough I feel like
it's something that I don't even know if
I could ever say it enough that i would
i would sit down and say okay i've said
this enough times you know you guys are
so supportive and you guys are so great
and there is a mosquito on my wall which
sucks i hate mosquitoes well you guys
are so supportive it you guys are so
awesome just in terms of like just being
supportive you know you guys always ask
such awesome questions and you guys
always have such great feedback you know
and it's just it's really awesome be
part of a community as good as this one
so you know I'm sorry if I get on and I
make these videos and it seems like I'm
overdoing it you know like I'm trying to
be Susan too sincere but but in all
honesty you know I'm just I'm really
humbled by everything that's happened so
far I'm really humbled by the fact that
my channel's hit 10,000 subscribers and
I'm really humbled by the fact that you
guys are just like hey Rob here's stuff
you can do to make your channel better
you know and I'm humbled by the fact
that the camera you know is doing
everything he can to help my channel
grow you know I'm humbled by the fact
that I've been as successful as I have
been because of what you guys have done
to support me you know because of all
the work that you guys have put in you
know when I look around I look at this
YouTube channel you know I don't look at
it as like my success like I am awesome
and it's not like you know I want to
thank myself for being as awesome as I
am you know this has been a group effort
you know this has been a group effort
between all you guys you know you guys
and me and all the work that we've put
in and all the suggestions that have
been made and all the advice and the
criticism that's that's been made and
it's just it's really cool so you know I
again I'm sorry if i come across as
being like you know like gushy kind of
you know like II too sincere you know
but I just I don't feel like I could
ever say to you guys enough times that
you guys are awesome you guys are really
really cool so you know just you know I
just I don't know
I'm not sure how to say it other than
that but I maybe I just can't get the
words out of my mouth but in any event
so so yeah you know it definitely make
sure you guys check out dave's channel
Dave's got really really cool content
and I'm really enjoying what he's doing
so far and you know just make sure that
you guys support him you know as well as
you guys are supported me which is
always kind of cool and yeah so on
thursday i'm probably gonna be live
streaming in the evening probably be
lashing around seven or eight o'clock
and maybe playing some bioshock 1 or
some bioshock 2 i'm not really sure yet
i know that a couple of you guys want me
to play bioshock infinite I don't know
is that stand alone can i play bioshock
infinite and never and you know and like
do fine understand what's going on if
i've never played bioshock 1 and to like
let me know because i don't know
anything about the Bioshock games I
don't know how those games are played
another play their first person shooters
but i don't know like this story if it's
like you have to have played the
previous two games in order to
understand you know what's going on in
the third game me i don't really know
how well that works but uh but yeah so
anyway um this is going on for like
seven minutes I'm going to bounce off
here and yeah I'm gonna catch some sleep
because it's like 130 in the morning so
I will catch you guys later peace